kaimana directeur exécutif de la
fondation samir kassir allemann anna
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france
votre réaction d'abord à ces images ces
scènes de violence dans les rues de
beyrouth vous étiez à cette
manifestation
racontez nous un petit peu comment on
comment s'est déroulé ce rassemblement
c'était une manifestation très
importante
l'une des plus grandes depuis le
déclenchement des manifestations le 17
octobre 2019
des groupes très divers étaient présents
sur place également avec des jeunes qui
ont tenté de s'approcher de l'enceinte
du parlement qui est bloquée par les
forces de l'ordre après 200 mètres du
parlement des deux côtés ouest est et
dès 17 heures il ya eu des échauffourées
des tentatives de dépasser les obstacles
qui était qui étaient mises en place et
les forces de l'ordre ont répliqué avec
une violence incroyable en termes de
dongs de lacrymogènes qui ont été
déversées de manière assez indiscriminée
dès 17h30
ce qui à ce qui était peut-être une
stratégie pour empêcher un rassemblement
encore plus important ça montre à quel
point les autorités sont fébriles
il ya eu un peu plus de 55 blessés il ya
eu un policier tué il y avait plusieurs
ministères qui ont été pris d'assaut par
les manifestants
on a l'impression d'un sentiment que les
libanais n'ont presque plus rien à
perdre
selon vous jusqu'où sont ils capables
d'aller c'est une question qu'il faudra
poser aux autorités politiques qui ont
démontré ces quatre derniers jours après
le drame incroyable qui a frappé notre
ville leur incapacité totale à assurer
le minimum de ce qui est demandé d'une
autorité responsable
ils se sont renvoyés la balle se sont
accusés les uns les autres de
d'être responsable de ce qui s'est passé
ce que nous savons en tant que libanais
c'est que toutes les autorités étaient
au courant du stockage de 2007 150
tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium juste même
le 20 juillet dernier le premier
ministre le président de la république
la ministre de la justice le ministre
des transports étaient tous mise au
courant par les services de sécurité de
saint-georges et et rien n'a été fait et
on sait que rien n'a été fait depuis
2013 puis 2014
ces autorités là y compris le président
de la république clame qu'il n'a pas par
exemple les prérogatives
une autre personne qu'il n'était pas
informé une autre une troisième personne
qu'elle n'était pas nécessairement au
courant
ça montre à quel point ces autorités
sont incapables de gérer quoi que ce
soit et imaginez leur incapacité à gérer
un événement de cette ampleur
face à cela les libanais ne peuvent plus
aujourd'hui près de 300 me libanais ne
peuvent pas dormir chez eux il y a
aujourd'hui une incapacité totale de
réparer les dégâts étant donné la crise
économique et l'effondrement de la livre
libanaise
même si on pouvait réparer même si on
avait les moyens
techniquement il est impossible
d'importer vu la destruction du port
face à cela les autorités ne font
absolument rien aucune responsabilité
politique aucune responsabilité pénale
et on a vraiment l'impression qu'elles
veulent tergiverser afin de revenir à la
normale comme d'habitude parce qu'au
liban depuis 30 ans plein de crimes ont
été commis
même depuis la guerre en 75 plein de
crimes ont été commis
rien n'a été fait puisque un responsable
et banana justement vous parlez du
gouvernement et ce diable premier
ministre libanais a annoncé qu'il y
aurait des élections anticipées est ce
que cela suffira à calmer la couleur du
peuple qui est déterminé depuis des mois
on sait samedi on a raté une excellente
occasion soit de démissionner soit de se
taire parce qu'il a joué avec les mots
il n'a pas annoncé des élections
anticipées
il a dit qu'il proposera lundi au
gouvernement au conseil des ministres
d'organiser des élections anticipées de
proposer un projet de loi qui serait
envoyé au parlement pour que le
parlement accepte de réduire son mandat
de raccourcir son manga est donc d'aller
vers des élections anticipées
c'est donc rentrer dans un jeu politique
ridicule d'une lenteur qu'on connaît au
liban ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'on ce qu'on se perd dans des méandres
législatif administratif et
bureaucratique
alors qu'on lui demande une seule chose
c'est pour une fois de sa vie de se
comporter en responsable c'est un homme
qui a su au moins le 20 juillet dernier
même avant que il y avait au port ce
stockage de manière très dangereuse et
il n'a absolument rien fait il a dit je
n'étais pas conscient je m'occupais
d'autres dossiers
je me permets de vous interrompre car on
a un petit peu pris par le temps
pourquoi selon vous michel en au
président libanais refuse l'idée d'une
enquête internationale le président
michel lang ne veut pas connaître la
vérité et ne veut pas que le peuple
libanais connaissent la vérité 1 sur ce
qu'il savait lui même depuis son
accession à la présidence
quant à ce port il ne veut pas qu'on
sache ce qui se trame au port de manière
légale et illégale aussi concernant
différentes parties libanaises
il ne veut pas que les personnes qui le
protège qui sont corrompus soient
exposées et il protège de ce fait là
toute la classe politique même les gens
qui officiellement sont six opposants
certains certains libanais demande à
être sous mandat français pendant dix
ans c'est une décision qui peut sembler
surprenante comment est-ce que les
libanais en sont arrivés là
je pense que c'était une forte de
d'appel qui était beaucoup plus
émotionnel que réelle
aucun parti politique aucune composante
même de la révolution ne pense à cela
aujourd'hui les libanais envoie en
disant cela un signe de dégoût et de
dédain et de refus total à l'égard de
cette classe politique il accepterait
presque tous manga tout gouvernant sauf
celle de ces partis qui depuis 75 et
surtout depuis 30 ans ont conduit le
pays à sa misère et surtout à la mort de
centaines de personnes
selon vous quelle est quelle est la
solution pour avoir une perspective
d'avenir à tous ces jeunes libanais qui
veulent pouvoir vivre paisible
et qui veulent pouvoir grandir dans leur
pays les solutions sont à court terme et
à long terme à court terme rapidement
organisés de manière très efficace
l'aide internationale hors des
structures de l'état libanais en
organisant à un certain parrainage
international de cette aide
en allant directement à la population à
travers des ong que tous les bailleurs
de fonds connaissent et respectent
deuxièmement une enquête internationale
et troisième mois un appui libanais et
internationales pour un gouvernement
réellement indépendant d'experts qui va
mettre toute la lumière sur ce qui s'est
passé
prendre des mesures contre la corruption
et permettent le retour de l'aide
internationale au liban ce n'est que
lorsque l'aide internationale de court
terme et l'aide économique reviendra
qu'on pourra remettre en oeuvre remettre
sur place notre vie économique et
rétablir une forme de normalité mais
avec cette classe politique
c'est complètement impossible c'est même
naïf de prétendre croire et c'est ce que
je dirai à charles michel c'est ce que
j'ai personnellement dit à jean yves le
drian et ce qui a été dit à emmanuel
macron avec cette classe politique ce
serait naïf d'attendre quoi que ce soit
qui aille dans un sens des réformes et
de la lutte contre la corruption à
émanera de la merci beaucoup pour cet
éclairage rappelle que vous êtes
directeur exécutif de la fondation samir
kassir merci à vous